auf und davon spezial wird ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade
korsika sind anja kinski unter chlodwig
man mit ihrem hund tina profi thalia sie
an den ur alter hof übernahm zum großes
agriturismo mache
der umbau hattenhofen und langer schlaf
braucht
alles hat viel länger dritter sieg meint
end
geschäft mit
ihren hof wachst 91 websites geiße und
hörnern russ
alles schien gut
aber den wir d'italia vor schwere
erdbeben erschüttert mit string-tanga
unter glut ihren hofstaat maberzell sind
massiv das kürzlich weltkriegen haupt
muren eine für hingerichtet es staubt
da war es dann klar okay es hat jetzt
auch uns erwischt sie dem erdbeben
schlafen die beiden im wohnwagen
zuversicht 1 0 verloren
[Musik]
da sich in auswanderer schicht wodurch
schicksal umgeschrieben wird aber von
einem weiß ich nicht und ich im letzten
herbst auf mittelitalien unterwegs bin
absurd anja und blut im oktober vom
letzten jahr zu mehr stimmung
die dahlie wohnens im below san martino
iris agriturismo lied versteckt
empfangskomitee
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo
da wurde mir immer gespielt
[Gelächter]
das einzige tier das schon aus der
schweiz mit nach italien kommt ist gino
damals noch ein kleiner welpe dass hunde
mami muss abschied nehmen und 2010
wanderkino aus nach italien nach san
martin
ursprünglich suchten anja kinski und
chlodwig man ja nur ein ferienhaus doch
dann entschlossen sie sich ihr leben
gleich richtig auf den kopf zu stellen
[Musik]
denn es hat sturm glück gehabt
also
gino gucken ob irgendwelche fremden hier
hausen
china
hinein
[Musik]
daraus hat was strom für im moment aber
wenn wir es auch die kollegen für
respekt
[Musik]
zu beginn ist alles improvisiert doch
auch auf eine luftmatratze kann man
große träume haben die wärme der natur
und der ersten führung gemacht haben das
ganze gefühl start stopp automatik sie
das mal überhaupt über erinnern können
sie wohne ich schlussendlich kann man
jetzt ohne drehen sind das waren wir
definierten aus honig und da soll dann
eine wohngemeinschaft mit dem schmiede
und natürlich stürzt ist aber dass man
von nation hat eine frau sie für das
gedrehten films durch einen mittleren
sechsstelligen betrag hat das anwesen
gekostet nun soll daraus dass
agriturismo duelle entstehen in viel
stahl will claude zum gästezimmer
umbauen
früher löste der berber probleme in
langwierigen sitzungen nun greift er zum
hammer anja kümmert sich um die
tierische seite des agriturismo
eigentlich wirklich alles gut aus wir
waren ja auch mal auch im markt gewesen
und da hatten sie für auch hühner in
denn so gut aus haben viele federn
gefehlt und die machen mir jetzt einen
gesunden eindruck ich muss zugeben ich
habe nicht so wahnsinnig viel ahnung von
dem thema
anja war in ihrem früheren leben
betriebsökonomie bei einem großen
deutschen technologiekonzern vorstellen
dann der erste erfolg im noch jungen
bauern leben der anja kinski komme ich
mal hier
da liegt 1 unser erstes ein paar monate
später kommen noch mehr tiere dazu
höchste groß geworden und je nach
rennsituation mit sieben ersten zehn
schaffen sie sich ebenfalls an für die
käseproduktion
fuchs
schleppender geht es mit dem bau der
gästezimmer verhandelt
lange hat es gut alleine versucht nun
holt er sich professionelle hilfe
winziger aber es ist natürlich einfach
so wendig und passt ja nicht alle
maschinen auch neue möglichkeiten
ein folgenreicher bauch
[Musik]
vier sportler ist begrüßte die us fotos
mal fertig es braucht nur noch nie
innenausbau langsam rutschig sind
unterwegs zu der sauer
es ist für tricks wir beide ein recht
zur kleid sitzt auf dem hof sind auf der
seite zur stehen drei ross und zwei
fohlen dass ich überhaupt so dass ihr
aussehen ihr aus sicht der haut ja und
zwar ein halber zwei verheißt somit
besonders frauen ja überraschend voller
hass also will wieder raschen will mir
groß kauft hat aber eine stute kraft
nach modell zum industrie damals ich mit
begeisterung und eines tages warmsroth
auch standen wirklich große überraschung
dann auch eines morgens haltern 2005
auszudrücken
diese auf sehr gute investition so viel
heu
bild.de hinzu und es wäre neues baumann
ö 2 motor bibliothek die anja und ein
schon richtige bohrer hof benannt und
dann gibt es ja noch geist worin
versorger beziehen
[Applaus]
hallo ich bin ja so das ist jetzt hier
ein erst rocken
eine so erfahrene ehemalige staunt sind
zwei tödliche zimmer wurde reagiert
ihres geschäfts ja es ist noch ein
gewisser weg also selbsttragend je
nachdem wie man es auch sieht also wenn
man jetzt sagt nur dass wir jetzt davon
leben können dann denke ich mal sind wir
auf einem guten weg wenn man jetzt in
betracht zieht dass wir ja noch einige
investitionen zu tätigen haben dann ist
es noch ein etwas längerer weg
agriturismo naturelle liebt recht
abgelegen truman tanja und der woche für
ihre gäste
die dort gibt es vier gang menü - und
alles im eigenen garten tulln cottbuser
blieben nur die chino knies der
vorzugsbehandlung
[Musik]
das nächste große projekt ein die beiden
muss waren draußen group als richtiges
rechte rand mit großer hoch
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen ist anja früher
unterwegs
sie geht einmal pro woche schuhe und
zählt noch ein zweiter job wo sie sich
achtung für standardisierung von
testverfahren brandmelder in europa
gesetzt was für ein kontrast zum bohrer
lebe vom gymnasium in san diego und
richtet anja tisch auf dem acker
tourismus sind wir ja so ein bisschen
abgeschieden und haben mehr kontakt mit
den gästen und wir sind natürlich alle
italiener italienerin und das ist
eigentlich auch das schöne was mir
gefällt an dieser arbeit neben der
arbeit natürlich mit den mit den
schülern morgen besonders viel für die
enten jahr dort aber all die bauern dort
euro hohes gut buche
wie geht es euch brot ja wie waren eure
ferien francesca hast du etwas gemacht
in den ferien miriam
[Musik]
aha und hatte auch ein bisschen deutsch
gesprochen sehr gut
logisch die haie am werk in das bazl aus
unsere gäste muss endlich fertig sie
haben die zusätzlichen isoliert jetzt da
wir jetzt unterwegs waren
da machen jetzt gibt's beruf machen wir
halt du hilfst mir schlepper diesem jahr
lang darf sorge dass ich hoffe ich dass
die richtigen maße was david luftlöcher
passt noch mal über alles im wahlkampf
musste zuerst herrscht eine weile da
sagt man hat das mit vorverlegt
[Musik]
motor wie so ein fachmann sehr
kompliziert gehabt ok und einer posse
oder dagegen dass die plötzlich
runterbringt machen wir etwas verpasst
sein will ist ein hammer aus
du bist ja soll ein hoffnungsloser
optimist multipliziert aber ich finde
und so besser durch habe man darum
irgendwie gott und gegen den bug winter
sind ja immerhin war das land dann
einfach jedes mal auf sich denn dann das
sollte nicht auffangen
es ist ein heißer tag irgendwie möglich
sein das ist vieles machen immer zu
hause also ohne optimismus bringst du
das nicht öfter und dann wird es doch
noch schön wie mehr stück durch träger
heizungs liebe findet anja ich bin gern
mit
obwohl die von rite wenig bis gar nie
verstehen dass eines russischen
kindheitstraum von der anja wieso es
heisst perl
das wurde anja los der name so viel
arbeit
jetzt musste erstmal mit diesem teil für
den dreck das war mal so aufwirbeln oder
oder raus fürstensohn kreisenden
bewegungen
sie haben die brala ja aber warum hat
denn dort so lang du siehst du dir
selbst so kaufte es ja das war
eigentlich durch ein ja einen
unerwarteten zwischenfall ich war vor
dreieinhalb jahren plötzlich und
unerwartet sehr schwer krank hatte
brustkrebs und wurde dann operiert
inzwischen geht es mir ja eigentlich
wieder sehr gut und jedenfalls habe ich
dann damals nachdem das ganze also
überstanden war mir gesagt warum sollte
jetzt eigentlich warten also das macht
einem dann ja bewusst dass vielleicht
man doch nicht 80 wird und dann habe ich
gesagt jetzt mach ich jetzt kaufe ich
mir die pferde oder nichts spiel
aussieht ist eigentlich ein
schicksalschlag die krankheit eigentlich
wieder moment wo du noch mal alles die
frage stellt was weißt du wo du dir mal
was war zählt eigentlich nur kurz
naja so extrem würde ich es vielleicht
nicht darstellen hat jetzt nicht alles
infrage gestellt ich habe das projekt
hier zum beispiel überhaupt nicht in
frage gestellt oder mehr so auch ein
stück heute als belohnung ich habe das
jetzt überstanden
und warum soll ich jetzt so viel warten
und gegen alle unvernunft ich kaufe
jetzt ein oder zwei pferde und so kam es
dann auch
hier sieht sie jetzt hat zukunft weit
ich weiß nicht ob da aber 70 gange
die quälerei zu ihrer jungs kann
normalerweise liest sich aber sehr spät
diejenige bevor ich mit dieser große
maschinen unterwegs bin und mit denen
schöne bilder redigiert schicht rené
zentgraf user-namen das nunmehr dritte
experte naturkatastrophe alles verändert
[Musik]
serife erdbeben erschüttert italien
ganze dörfer sind zerstört und zeisige
von menschen obdachlos
[Musik]
übers internet meldet sich dann unter
blut und schrieben vor starke schäden
muss und dass sie im auto übernachten
[Musik]
denn bt oder normal so stark wie noch
nie
funkstille
[Musik]
meldet sich die beiden wieder stöhnt
sind aber instabil und drum mit sitzt im
wagen schlafen
und wo es fast nie mehr schlimm auch in
tirol und dann hatte große schnee
[Musik]
so geht's jetzt dazu sind so martin 200
meter weg von anja und bluetooth zur
sperrzone erklärt worden
das wollten die momentan
mitte mai molekül im buch bin unterwegs
zum 22 wie anja und lud sie sind fast
die einzige wurde region bliebe sind weg
grüns und wenn's nicht
[Applaus]
hallo hallo
okay die ist eines tages hier einfach
angekommen stand auf dem weg und dann
haben wir uns dann haben wir uns
umgehört wen sie gehören könnte ob sie
getippt ist nichts also naja also
gegenüber dem was was mir das letzte mal
gesehen wie völlig anders ja ja weil wir
ja jetzt im wohnwagen schlafen und
die häuser die wurden als in agb erklärt
also sprich wir dürfen eigentlich nicht
mehr rein
obwohl sie hier noch stehen aber ich
sehe eigentlich nicht viel oder sogar
relativ gut die ganze hinterteil und
erinnern wird darum eine störung waren
auch die große schade und untersteht
traten die modelle glos was wir sind
eigentlich befragt das indierock davos
kommen sollte dass ich im notfall heißt
wir können wohl kommt pro winter wir
hatten zurückgekauft
dank haben wir an zwei gotteshäuser doch
so mancher bis anmache und risiko
schlafen tagsüber warschau
ich weiß ja nicht einmal erahnen
irgendwann sich dauner was mir an den
wohnwagen in dem buch kauft im jahr
die dahlie des rings um das kamikaze hat
natürlich an der wohnwagen oder
wohnmobil
und dann sind briesen einfach gehasst
größe 30 euro mehr zahlen und der hat ja
alles top alles dicht krass probleme
zuerst müssen sie auch nicht so wichtig
es ist kalt mit nassen füßen aufgemacht
der firma schnellen blick auch noch
schnell noch mal hektisch lang wird es
etwas kühler
früher fertig sein mit dem ja aber wie
gesagt also mit der heizung geht das
eigentlich also es ist sogar so dass ich
ja ja die stellen wir dann abends an und
dann wird es teilweise auch zu warm
also dann stelle ich sie wieder ab
frau sie paradies ist sie zu erstatten
das zumindest das ist dass ich geblieben
so scheint sich alles frei
positiv seien die depressionen verfassen
trotz knapper kasse im und nutzte ihn
detail vom hausdach gestürzt
schade ich haben offensichtlich steht
der andere weniger schlimm muss trotzdem
sind häuser unbewohnbar
ein anderes ist die ganze weggerissen
wurde aus fußes chance bekommt rand der
gesellschaft bewusst dass dresden beide
tore ging aber schaut dir waren dahin
wieder hoch ich hatte einfach risiko
werden gesegnet so offensichtlich aber
der ganz teilorts christen nicht statt
leerer drin also das feld drückt
konkurrent würde kein kuchen oder ins
bett aber noch schlafzimmer und im
sommer läuft sie im rennen ist und wenn
es mich und dann beim kälte ist das
erdbeben passiert ich weiß nicht wo die
srg sie also wenn es richtig schlimme
für richtig schlimme erdbeben strich
also vom heimischen hof der sonntag ist
einer statistik sich an da weil eine
katze führte etwas aufgefangen hat und
wenn möglich dann hat terrasse
dachterrasse weg und das gehört wie es
wirklich wie haupt muren eine starke
kräfte riss staub ruß ausstoßen zimmer
gerannt an der uni gestanden und er ist
für sforza will du merkst du auch schon
fast nur knapp startschuss tauschte sich
aus bewegt ist zuerst mal quasi
unfassbar was überhaupt passiert ist das
nicht etwas leichter als letztes sie so
mit normal ist scheiße erdbeben und dann
hat es stark das holz welche nachbeben
und dass man alle vier eigentlich kann
das ist aber ist hoffentlich das aber
dafür dann christoph vorher haben wir
immer gesagt ja wir hatten glück und bei
uns ist es eigentlich nicht sind keine
so großen schäden
und dieser letzte
das letzte erdbeben da war uns dann klar
okay es hat jetzt auch uns erwischt
eigentlich kann man sagen ja also das
war es dann schon klar dass wir jetzt
auch schäden haben die so schnell jetzt
nicht mehr reparierbar sein würden wie
viel macht haben wir das erträge ist
gott in drogen was da alles ist
unwahrscheinlich viel energie und willen
die raum mit viel licht da mit mit dem
film ghost droht ist nach ständig
bedroht haben
das war für uns auch bis heute haben wir
noch nicht einmal wir beide diskutiert
wollen wenn ich doch weggehen oder
wieder zurückgehen in die schweiz
also wir sind noch wir haben unseren
optimismus immer noch nicht verloren und
sind nach wie vor entschlossen hier zu
bleiben
da konnten sich natürlich andere
finanziell was man durchaus als alles
geld und pensionskassen finanziell ist
es natürlich auch weil wir müssten ja
dass hier verkaufen dann kaufen wenn
jetzt momentan niemand also mit services
wie schlimm dass es wirklich stadt wisse
die beiden gar nicht wie sie es nur
schnell beurteilung von einer häuserecke
sieht woche war das drum auf der
ingenieur boostedter definitiv selber
urteilen kam es noch dicker oder wo es
alles abgerissen werden dort bauarbeiter
oder fünf ja ganz viele offene fragen
uns einzig wo die beiden machen ist
es ist leider ein junger hund aber dass
beamte vor der region unmittelbar machen
mehr überhand behörde der anja und dem
claude not viel versprochen
ein wohncontainer und das provisorium
für stahl und für ganze winter und die
beide gewartet jetzt gold eintritt bis
die sind jetzt dauer war ein container
hostie machte zwar stehen die nächstens
hoffentlich von der wand und die
provisorischen stau provider behörden
mit probeweise genau zuständig für den
widerruf buch aber gibt hier nicht so
viele stellen wo dann um 10 weiß
natürlich will ich auch haben wir hier
den platz einfach ein besseres honig
oder drüber und wo wollte den stall
haben
hier bekommt ihr einen großen stein
brauchen dort bei den pferden unfälle
und beim us masters premiere zementieren
was jetzt doch so schnell und dann wäre
zeit straßen opitz mache hat wo eine
riesenfläche anja betreiben kommt er
immer war wollten ohnehin noch am tag
danach wenn der wohnung konnte erinnert
ein wieder weg blieb fundament übrig als
parkplatz dazu ein stall für
kanalisation und drainage das alles mit
anja und der glut mit deren unterschrift
vom italienischen staat über hoffe
zufall
so jetzt schampus bevor es landstrich
tanja bevorstehen stimmungsdämpfer
glaube das ist super und ich bin in den
usa kanada ist viel kaputt
die ganze platte i um kate sind wo sie
sind
die schwere scheibe sogleich seine sache
sind sicher nicht schnell mit der spitze
mehr pflegt das wird der italienische
staat hat zwar versprochen er zahle
alles aber vielleicht blieben da seien
immer schön wenn ihr preisgeld
wir gehen momentan davon aus dass wir
was bekommen sind optimistisch ein die
umwelt durch die siebte im prinzip ja
nie was drin ist recht raums investiert
ausstrahlen können auch ein neues stahl
investiert was man für tiere weniger
albert hat aber jetzt thomas haupt
android ios und das ist natürlich
schwierig weil mehr und wer damit
kalkuliert dass man wenig behindert und
wenn dann zwei jahren über 2000 gäste
extrem mehrausgaben da eigentlich noch
irgendwie groß stufe also das wird ja
wir müssen in jedem fall den gürtel
enger schnallen
so schön sagt dania ihre beiden
evergreens sind jetzt umso wichtiger zum
schluss zeigen mir die klotener was ihm
am meisten sorge macht der ecke vom
oberen hus wird quasi nur noch vom ev
ebit und klargestellt dass die ganze
fassade gefühle gibt uns unsere wohnhaus
komplett zerstört und mit der gleichen
stärke wie im november dann passiert das
ist alles total glücklich sein wollen ja
fast vergessen
nicht normal ist er bekommt was tanja
und dem claude haut und struktur gibt
sind die regierung sieht dem erdbeben
fast jeden abend aus dem wald zu der 43
[Musik]
ein neuer morgen auf dem hof dressur l
wieder den tag lieber im provisorium
[Musik]
im wohnwagen snow schlaufe 14 wochen
büro wcs ist geiste hässlich halten sie
den boom einzige schwer beschädigt wurde
zählen sie drohen nur selten laufen und
auch nur einen tag gibt es ein warmes
wasser dusche ich zum luxus wurde aber
im vergleich zu vielen anderen war ja
nicht so könnte man ja sagt krömer ja
wenigstens das auch nutzen
obwohl was nicht da fällt man halt
einfach frei ins risiko will und
wohnwagen zum organization die beiden
anderen hufes tour sie werden jetzt mit
landwirtschaft setzen wie es ja für
unbestimmte zeit keine rente
sehr schön tanja und upload jetzt aber
überholen
im härter winter ist irre führt seine
gruppe unter der last von der anderthalb
meter schnee
nur dafür die lage jetzt im nachbardorf
15 minuten weg vom agriturismo
die heuballen das geschenk der wind
irgendwann mal einen upgrade der ebene
gehört dass das schwierig stürzt und sie
würde doch es trifft alle bringen
mit dem salz laptop und der frau super
super gern und so also wir sind froh und
dann aber hat irgendwann ein offizielles
amt gefunden so vage sechs oder acht
rosenbauer geister 30 eine notelf die
übel parteien nicht nur geküsst und das
team ist auf jeden fall sieht man schon
froh klinikum die 15
witzel frustrierend dass dann die
anderen 15 fahrzeugen die unter allen im
stall hat jede schuld aber wie gesagt
man ja immerhin 15 prozent und qualität
ist wirklich sehr gut
also schmeckt sehr gut der postmärkte
geistern also maßnahmen
noch im erdbeben tanja und grosse
solidarität erlebt ehemalige nachbarin
diene essen kleider verbraucht
wildfremden leuten die das internet
apotheke helfen
anders als in der schweiz italien davon
aus dass man sich auf viel vom staat
nicht fallen
und darum helfen sich untereinander
seite glut musste einen moment vor der
unterstützung und bei die viel kraft
geschöpft
ja
aufsteller seit geburt vor dem china
hängt sie dafür eigentlich nötige im
stau steht
er ist gesperrt aber es gibt gar keine
andere möglichkeit zum wohle warum
weiter schützen zweite stunde und ins
bad nachwuchs
doch wieder da ist meinte sich weg aber
schon ab minute vor der größten pleite
staat mit der bcp kripo hof und sind die
wunderbare landschaft und gleichzeitig
auf kette vom baby was ich das jetzt für
ihre ziele vor augen was ist das für das
ja-wort
das abwarten 7 einfach mehr machen was
machen was man überhaupt projekt mädchen
machen die eher mäßig oder pcs land
wirtschaftlich wieder schaffe ein
klassik event mit dem was vorher da war
es wieder schaffen wie wenig sie wer die
zukunft ich auch so unsichere moment
müssen wir müssen weil wir im grunde
genommen keine keine alternative haben
aber wir wollen auch ein und muss immer
nicht funktioniert also ein bürojob
assange soll gesagt haben renault toyota
und glauben nicht mit
es gab halt hin und her und jetzt ist
halt mal auf der eine sieht und wie man
ja auch durch die andere sieht schlimmer
aus
anja und upload wirklich beeindruckend
wie positiv sich die unsichere zukunft
zwei wochen später schrieb er sich
endlich für die eu erreichen
[Musik]
nach stufe gott abruft florida
vor sechs jahren ist familie denn zur
ausgewandert als formierte heinz
turbulent die zieht sich neuerdings
tochter larissa der uni und nehme viel
dh der für körper altbekannte
hochdruckreiniger immer noch zum 1
ziel ist es bis dahin die kasse
die sonne
[Musik]
auf und davon spezial wurde ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade